speaking of the international sphere
though other weird stuff going on
scientists at the University of
Pittsburgh Medical Center who was
reportedly on the verge of making quote
very significant findings in the fight
against the corona virus was murdered
over the weekend inside his home
neighbors said that he and his wife kept
to himself a very quiet guy and yet he
was found murdered and the person who
they think murdered him then left and
killed himself in a car right down the
street
very odd now we know the the the doctor
by the way is dr. Bing Lu 37 he's from
China he was shot multiple times and
they believe he was shot by another man
how gu 46 who was lived in Pittsburgh he
may have been from China himself then he
got in his car 100 yards away and killed
himself wonder what that's about I guess
it could be a coincidence but it doesn't
feel like a coincidence it feels like
maybe there's something else going on
here we know that China has covered up
this whole epidemic from the very
beginning the Chinese government said
initially it had no idea what was
happening if the Chinese government said
initially the virus has no connection to
the market chinese government says
originally though the World Health
Organization says originally no don't
don't look over there now all of a
sudden as people are investigating this
all of a sudden people go dead people
turn up dead if we were not so concerned
about the masks and the craziness
surrounding that maybe we pay a little
bit more attention maybe this is giving
cover for some people who are who are
interfering in international politics in
ways we couldn't possibly even speculate
on it's not just them though okay it's
not just this international sphere it's
not just Barack Obama goes all the way
to the mainstream media goes all the way
to Hollywood there were big changes that
could possibly happen in this country
and they might happen without us even
knowing what hit us if we don't pay
closer attention
[Music]